[Applaus]
wenn wir sie schon mal darum haben sie
handy dabei ist da das video drauf ja
nein es ist nicht doch nein es ist
tatsächlich nicht drauf das war eine
gute überlegung das kann ich aus
sicherheitsgründen gemacht ja also
wussten dass die frage kommt weil eines
war klar ich sag mal wenn ich mir das
video hätte schicken lassen und durch
amine wege wieder ist in berlin manchmal
so ist da bleibt ja manchmal was in der
straßenbahn liegen oder wie auch immer
wenn das jetzt in den redaktionen
gelandet wäre dann hätte wahrscheinlich
so mancher gesagt na da hat er am tor
sein video jetzt weitergegeben deshalb
habe ich gesagt schickt es mir nicht ich
kenne es ich hab es aber nicht auf dem
handy
ja natürlich kennen sie sich habe es ja
selbst gemacht klar darf ich mal
nachgucken haben sie es da dass das
zählt das habe ich hier damit die
sendung reibungslos abläuft natürlich
mit flugmodus in der grube gelassen ist
ja wir können das kurz das ist gar kein
problem aber wir gucken mal nach
zusammen ja ja ich habe es tatsächlich
nicht drauf aber immerhin was zur hölle
ist an diesem video so merkwürdig dass
sie es nicht mal drauf haben auf ihrem
handy um das keiner sehen darf also ich
bin auch erstaunt gewesen wo sie schon
ehrlich sagen wie sehr so video
irgendwie die gemüter erhitzen konnte
sowohl das von rieso als auch mainz und
das hat ja irgendwie die nachrichtenlage
so verrückt bestimmt ja ich war
unterwegs nach dem drehten meinem
wahlkreis und kommunalwahlkampf an der
polnischen grenze
da hat es die leute nicht so bewegt das
thema und ich muss sagen na ja es wurde
halt schon intensiv diskutiert und
einstimmt jenseits des videos und des
inhalts kann man auf jeden fall daraus
ableiten war das beste kommunikation vor
der europawahl ich würde sagen nein
müssen wir als parteien alle nicht nur
die cdu uns hat jetzt besonders im fokus
getroffen aber müssen wir alle ein
bisschen was dazu lernen wie man
vernünftig den ton des internet dürftig
glaubt ja und ansonsten das video als
solches ist gar nicht so spektakulär
sondern also ich sage nicht wo sie sagen
dass auch das auch also ist das video ja
du dich sagen so hat sie zu julia
presseerklärung sache ja und alle diese
gesehen haben fans auch so und es lag
auch nicht an inhalt sondern es lag
wirklich letztlich dann an der frage
welches format ist eigentlich der
richtige weg um dazu anfangen und dann
gab's mancherlei sorge zu sagen wenn wir
jetzt video
gibt es da eine video schlag kann man
andere themen selbst an land das war da
die diskussionslage am handy text noch
drauf ja das waren insgesamt zwei
stunden die kann ich ihnen jetzt nicht
kostenfrei studieren zwei stunden
gedreht also okay dann ist das wie genau
der erste satz mühe ihre kamera an chlor
bitte schön doch sehr interessieren den
kleinen spoiler mache ich jetzt daran
fantastisch hey wieso du alter zerstört
so war der erste sagt
es kann auch noch ein paar inhalte ich
würde jetzt ja verstehen dass wir rasen
sie interessiert am 2
na ja aber ich glaube wir haben ein sehr
wir haben heute auch andere gutes lernen
das machen wir jetzt nicht so also ich
habe der zweite worum ging es denn da
also inhaltlich jetzt also inhaltlich
ging es darum dass ein bisschen zu
reflektieren ich habe natürlich eine
inhaltliche auseinandersetzung maria hat
dem was so gesagt hat vor allem vier
themenfelder waren es das intim die wir
nicht erst seit antwort auf so ein
youtube-video diskutieren sondern ich
finde wichtig man muss sehen das sind
die themen die uns immer begegnen er war
das thema bildung das thema soziales das
thema klima umwelt natürlich und ein
bisschen um außenpolitik ging es dann
auch richtig und vor allem so wie es in
dieser pdf-datei ja auch drin steht ja
richtig die haben sie nicht vorgelesen
nein ich habe nicht die pdf-dateien
folge diese ein bisschen mehr fans ist
die cdu schon also dass das ganze ja
bürgerliche und dass eben dieses
bisschen auch verächtliche darum müssen
wir uns eigentlich gar nicht so ernst
nehmen was die was die youtuber da
machen und auch die ganzen jugendlichen
die dann immer mehr wurden naja dann
hatte schon den eindruck dass man da
irgendwie überhaupt nicht sprechen ich
war überhaupt nicht adäquat war die
sprache nicht verstanden es ist es ist
ja auch in er ihr sogar einmal zerstörer
ich krieg diesen satz ja ja ja danach
wie ist aber ein bisschen ist
wahrscheinlich dass man das denn dann
die schöne sendezeit die wir jetzt haben
sie den text sich überlegt mit
unterstützung vom adenauer haus ja wer
ist denn das adenauer haus am tor bitte
mit unterstützung der mitarbeiter die
das fleißig gemacht haben im
konrad-adenauer-haus tja das ist in
mehrere die die wo wir den text dann
zusammenarbeitet wer weiß dass profis
oder willst dass die arbeit nur profis
in der cdu landesgeschäftsstelle aber
ehrlich ohne quatsch dass fleißig
gemacht und ich frage deswegen weil es
hieß dass sein auch agenturen beteiligt
gewesen also beraten der agenturen von
außen jetzt wie gesagt ich würde das
video jetzt nicht so über erhöhen wir
haben gesagt dass er eine möglichkeit
gewesen zu antworten aber wie lassen
sich zeigen desto wichtiger wird dieses
video ich habe schon gesagt das wäre
doch mal ein toller highlight für den
zdf-jahresrückblick oder also irgendwie
doch da kommt schon wieder ein spiel in
den marktpreis steigern
nein aber im ernst es ist ja also kader
hat das ja gesagt natürlich die
diskussion im politischen berlin gingen
natürlich heißt dann weil es dann auch
bei den redaktionen schon bekannt war
dass dieses video gemacht wurde
dann waren riesige erwartungen da bei
twitter wurde viel diskutiert
ich habe schon immer gesagt das wird ein
bisschen so wie bei rocky vier so rocky
balboa gegenüber antrag und wenn ich
glaube kann szene dann rockig oder weil
sie ich glaube ich hätte gewonnen ja
aber eigentlich jetzt gar nicht darum so
zu sagen da so eine summe kampf
konstellation abzubilden sondern
eigentlich war wirklich das interesse da
wie reagiert jetzt die union auf dieses
video und so kurz vor der wahl war man
dann ehrlich gesagt schon sehr erstaunt
wie lange das gedauert hat es gab ja
auch verschiedene versionen warum ihr
video nicht gezeigt wurde sicher version
kennen sie ja es kann zum beispiel die
version dass eben der generalsekretär
paul signac antworten sollte als
derjenige der eben sozusagen nach der
hausordnung im adenauer haus in der
parteizentrale von der funktion her
der richtige ist er antwortet man gesagt
hat das kann jetzt nicht ein einfacher
abgeordneter wie sie antworten und das
sind natürlich zum beispiel auch sachen
finde ich die da draußen sein wenn
vertreten dass das ist auch quatsch also
das gehört zu den gerüchten die auch
einfach nicht stimmen die papagena aus
dem anfahren besseres zu tun hat ja auch
sagt und ich bin auch sagen polizzi mark
und ich sind sind befreundet wir haben
da ein astreines verhältnis und er katar
in der situation kann er sich da gar
nichts vorwerfen und solche theorien das
ist dann irgendwie auch das gewesen dann
haben einiges an dem abend war nicht da
jetzt ist noch im slot frei jetzt müssen
wir beim schreiben dann hat das mancher
so abgeleitet daran lag es nicht also
privaten mich erstmal dass sie darauf
antworten dass sie das machen
es war die idee aus dem
konrad-adenauer-haus und wieder ja sie
sind gute oder das haus spricht zimmer
zu ja die sind echt bhs diesem haus hat
zu ihm gesprochen
jetzt werden das nicht über wir werden
jetzt hier nicht als große das große
protokoll machen und alles ausgehalten
es gibt doch endlich jemanden der sektor
und jetzt muster der am turm an der
mustersatzung ja ich kenne da jahres
liegen
ich kenne da jetzt nicht alle internen
abläufe ich habe einen anruf bekommen
wurde gesagt ich habe einen anruf
bekommen wurde gefragt ob ich es mache
und dann habe ich gesagt ja das ist was
wenn es die partei möchte das ist also
ist sie wie das gerade klingt wie anna
mafiafamilien damit wird nichts zu sagen
ich hab's ein angebot das nicht ganz so
als wenn die cdu es immer noch nicht
gelernt hätte mit youtube umzugehen ja
eigentlich hätte das sofort raus gemerkt
dass der spontane satz war doch super
und sie machen genau diesen gleichen
fehler und sagen jetzt überlegen wir
erstmal jetzt ist ganz zurück die ganze
welt ist jetzt scharf darauf dieses
video zu sehen was von spektakulärer ist
eigentlich dabei habe ich ja schon aber
ich finde sie machen dann fehler weil
ich finde also nicht der euro sondern
die ausnahme ist jan sehr
durchsetzungsstark
ein spritzer dank und auch sehr
sympathisch und werden wir das machen
frau gerade dieses video was bedeutet
das eigentlich wirklich ernsthaft in der
in der frage auch wie nah ist noch die
cdu überhaupt volkspartei wie nah sind
die drei anderen jungen leuten gott von
mighty gesehen die ich auch gleich
fragen würde gerade den kopf geschüttelt
hat aufgrund seiner einlassung die also
erst frau gerade dann weiter ja ich
finde das war eigentlich schon treffen
die sich schon länger ab wenn man die
zustimmungsraten in den verschiedenen
altersgruppen bei den unionsparteien
sich schon länger mal angeschaut hat
aber jetzt tatsächlich war die
europawahl spätestens und das war ja
nach diesem video gate nenne ich jetzt
mal wurde deutlich offenbar haben
die unionsparteien aber eben auch die
spd muss man aber sagen rechte und den
anschluss verloren an dir echt krass dem
sie die jungen leute und da muss man
dann auch die die altersgruppen anschaut
tatsächlich bis zu 60 jahren gehen bis
man tatsächlich bei der europa wahl zu
einem ergebnis kommt wo die union
stärkste politische kraft ist also alles
was unter 60 jahren war hat anders
gewählt und als volkspartei die sie ja
immer noch sein wollen und da müssen sie
glaube ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen
möglich kämpfen dass sie das bleiben
muss man die jugend stark lebe und
berücksichtigen die gruppe wird immer
kleiner
sprich sie hat nicht mehr so eine große
lobby macht die rentner werden immer
mehr
da machen sie auch ordentlich politik
aber das fällt ihnen auf die füße ich
glaube sich verlieren da gerade eine
ganze generation
und wenn man sich die parteitage
anschaut den letzten parteitag wo
annegret kramp-karrenbauer zur
vorsitzenden gewählt wurde da gab es ja
auch inhaltliche beratungen am anderen
tag
es wurde nicht ein bildungs antrag
bearbeitet das sind natürlich signale an
die jugend die verheerend sind
ich will das ist auf jeden fall auch ein
problem sage ich mal was auf jeden fall
dramatisch weiß ich glaube keiner in
einer union fand diese zahlen irgendwie
okay und gerade bei jungen wählern
verloren haben deswegen war das auch ein
großes thema auch jetzt auf der
klausurtagung des bundesvorstandes beim
nächsten parteitag unter anderem das ist
eines der themen wird man auch schauen
wie man auch moderne elemente einsetzen
müssen wir einfach besser werden weil
eine volkspartei bleibt man nur wenn man
sich immer wieder erneuert und dafür
müssen wir auch damit halten und das
feld allen parteien ehrlicherweise
moment schwer habe ich auch nicht nur um
moderne elemente wenn ich das noch gott
sagen das geht wirklich auch um inhalte
ich meine als als freiheit ist future
anfing wochen lang hat die union
lediglich auf dem schulschwänzen
herumgeritten und sich inhaltlich gar
nicht auseinandergesetzt und das sind
natürlich das ist von oben herab das ist
nicht angenommen die sind ja selber
indem alte unschuld fans gerade warum
minefinders anbieter sind jetzt nicht
nur schüler und sie wollen ja genauso
ernst genommen ja natürlich und deswegen
finde ich wichtig dass es jetzt kann ich
nochmal einsatz boilern der in dem
ressort video vorkam
wenn es um ernst nehmen geht da finde
ich immer auch findet auch nicht
unbedingt dass die grünen oder alle frei
disco future ernsten wenn man immer nur
sagt ihr habt alle recht sondern ich
persönlich konnte als junger
abgeordneter geht mir das ja auch
manchmal so dass man nicht immer voll
ernst genommen wird
ich fühle mich dann am meisten ernst
genommen wenn man inhaltlich mit mir
diskutiert und deswegen sage ich die
höchste form des ernst nehmen es ist
eigentlich der widerspruch
deswegen ist bei freitags fünf user um
das auch mal klar zu sagen bei alldem
wie wir einige inhalte nicht teilen muss
man glaube ich auch schon sehen das
ganze klima thema da stört mich schon
dass wir als union jetzt nur mit so
einer dagegen position wahrgenommen
werden und da das bewegt uns alle haben
ihre fraktionen diskutiert intensiv
gestern
da müssen wir auch gucken wie wir da ein
bisschen mehr an die vorankam hat das
ist das ein thema das haben sie gestern
in der fraktion intensiv diskutiert es
waren einmal auch jahren da war das
thema das thema insgesamt das auch
vorher diskutiert aber natürlich haben
wir in der nachlese der europawahl bei
vielen kollegen gestern auch ein
bedürfnis zu sagen dieses klima thema
ist nicht irgendwie was was man einfach
wegwischen kann ja aber das ist normal
sie sagen die ganzen inhalte formulieren
ernsthaft nach 20 jahren nach alsfeld
einen auch nach sein dass wir dann
ernsthaftesten einer in dem tritt ich
total entgegen wir müssen dann nur so zu
sagen nein wir haben das thema intensiv
in der fraktion haben die
klimabeauftragte anja weisgerber die das
ganz tüchtig macht wir haben
umweltpolitiker die da wichtig gute
sterben als in einem normalen unsere
selbst gesteckten klimazielen sie
unterschrieben haben und dass wir
deswegen nichts machen sondern eher
darauf kommt dass man das gefühl hat
wenn zum beispiel armin laschet bei der
kollegin anne will glaube ich war's dann
sagt es konnte ja keine ahnung dass
dieses klima thema in den letzten wochen
plötzlich so wichtig wie das was ganz
interessanter ist gesagt ich hätte
gesagt also ich glaube klimawandel war
ist schon seit 20 jahren thema und jetzt
plötzlich interessieren sich alle
bin ja total froh dass ich jetzt
plötzlich alle dafür interessieren denn
tatsächlich wissen wir das ja alle schon
ganz lang und das jetzt die
dringlichkeit auch bei der jugend
angekommen ist beides für future das ist
ja das tolle gerade und ja es ist das
nicht der kulturwandel aufbau karte der
jetzt gerade stattfindet und wo man das
gefühl hat dass professionelle politik
da wirklich überrollt wird oder
plötzlich junge leute sind die nicht
nach umfragen gucken den nicht auf
stimmungen gucken einfach sagen da gibt
es etwas und das erledigen wir jetzt
bitte genau also das habt ihr nicht doch
es gibt sie sogar egal wir machen genau
das gefühl die gesellschaft ist es waren
schon weiter als die politik und treibt
sie so ein bisschen vor sich her
natürlich sind die final four teilnehmer
auch nur ein ausschnitt das muss man
auch sagen also sind die gebildeten die
er aus gut situierten familien kommen
und so weiter die sich dafür
interessieren wir haben auch bei der
europawahl gesehen im osten deutschlands
wird anders gewählt und auch über der
jugend genau so grün sind da eben bei
weitem nicht so stark gewesen wie in den
westdeutschen bundesländern
das ist so klar alles nicht ist muss man
schon glaube ich ein bisschen genauer
drauf schauen und differenzieren aber
das thema ist da das thema glaube nicht
ausreichend bearbeitet es wurde
bearbeitet aber nicht ausreichend was
ich normal ist da geht es nicht um
angebot und nachfrage sondern da geht es
um eine gewisse dringlichkeit inserat
vorhin gesagt wie sie unterbrochen oder
wir sind kann ich dazu gekommen als es
um die frage ging inhaltliche
auseinandersetzungen sagten sie kurze
einwurf meine ich gehört zu haben
da hat ja gar nicht stattgefunden ich
habe genau das war das problem oder ist
das problem dass das was eben ankommt
nicht dieses ernst nehmen ist dass wir
uns inhaltlich auseinandersetzen und
vielleicht auch konkret über inhalte
sprechen und sagen hier widerspreche ich
aber oder hier ist es eigentlich
komplizierter als hier formuliert im
sangsoo sondern es war immer wieder
dieses signal jetzt geht doch mal in die
schule lass doch mal die profis machen
und das kam sehr sehr durch das nicht
eine partei ist das ist auch nicht so
dass alles durch wieso jetzt plötzlich
also ich bin insofern froh um das wiso
video weil
das jetzt eben die die nötige
aufmerksamkeit eben auch bei den
spitzenpolitikern geweckt hat denn das
also das passiert ja schon seit monaten
dieser frust wurde ja schon seit monaten
mit fein auf youtube genau mit den
artikel 13 17 demos da waren da war ein
großer teil der jugendlichen
generationen auch schon sehr mobilisiert
und da wurden sie auch schon ex also
drehen wir zurecht da ist das stichwort
und er genau was das bedeutet für den
täglichen umgang im internet wo es hat
ihre haltung dazu dass es mit der
materie zu erklären ja ich bin darum
dass im internet wenn ich jetzt
irgendwas hochladen oder etwas
produziere bin ich die urheberin und
wenn es jemand anderes benutzt einfach
für sich und damit auch noch geld macht
werbung seite ist es natürlich nicht so
toll und das muss irgendwie geschützt
werden ähnlich wie es auch in anderen
bereichen in den medien gesprochen so
alt gibt und so genau jetzt ist es aber
natürlich nicht nur so dass menschen
einfach mein video hochladen werbung
schalten sondern sich vielleicht
journalistisch damit auseinandersetzen
dass zitieren was einblenden unter das
mögen wir einen ort zitatrecht
zitatrecht satire dass man sich
satirisch damit auseinandersetzt und da
muss man natürlich differenzieren und
jetzt jetzt mit dieser mit der neuen
regelung werden jetzt die großen
plattformen wie zum beispiel youtube der
zur verantwortung gezogen dass alles was
dort hochgeladen wird muss muss geregelt
sein dass das auch kein verheben rechte
verletzt und das kann in dieser masse
ich weiß garnicht pro stunde werden
sie weiß ich wie viel stunden youtube
material hochgeladen
das kann man nicht redaktionell stemmen
das gibt dinge eigentlich nur über
sogenannte upload filter dhm fehlte ein
algorithmus der erkennt acht dieses
video ist das von der mai geht jetzt
gesperrt zum beispiel das ist teilweise
sehr fehlerhaft auch und dass die
expertinnen und experten sind sich einig
dass wir sind haben nicht die
technischen möglichkeiten der zeit das
anders zu regeln als durch upload filter
und das würde dann bedeuten dass ganz
viel ja ganz gut ich steh' ich habe ein
lustiges beispiel gelesen ich glaube
facebook hat mal ein
ein versuch damit gemacht und das wort
bush ging es um george double you busch
gesperrt sozusagen also nicht über ein
upload filter oder upload der reguliert
und gesperrt wurde dann auch alles was
kleingärtner betraf und friseure
weil der upload hilft beim stichwort
bush sei du hast auch bush gerade
benutzt laden wir nicht hoch
funktioniert nicht also das findest du
dann nicht ja und letztendlich waren
viele junge leute haben gesagt wir sind
total dafür urheber auch zu schützen
aber wir wissen wie wir stehen als wir
sind jeden tag auf youtube wir verstehen
dass das nicht funktioniert technischer
und da kamen auch leider sehr oft das
signal von der cdu viele kommentare die
gezeigt haben dass das überhaupt nicht
verstanden wird und was ist ja geht also
eine fehlende kompetenz in eine politik
und gleichzeitig leider auch wieder
diese arroganz von oben herab nicht
ernst genommen werden
das ist was für für erwachsene lasst uns
mal politik machen
ihr habt ja keine ahnung das ist doch
mal zurück zudem zu dem video über das
wetter hat die ganze zeit sprechen zwei
fragen würde mich interessieren weil wir
gerade beim die band meint die diese 16
11 seiten pdf datei ich habe mir das
heute zu gemüte geführt noch mal in
aller ruhe hast du es gelesen die
antwort die replik der cdu auf dieses
wieso video
ich habe es gelesen aber ich könnte
jetzt auch ich könnte jetzt auch nicht
so wieder wiedergeben haben sie die 50
minuten riese video gesehen gagas ganz
habe ich ganz gesehen habe ich ganz
gesehen haben sehr angeschaut
also hat schon nerv getroffen von der
kommunikationsart ich glaube
gleichzeitig muss aber auch klar sein
und ist die freiwillige wählt man machen
kann eine partei genauso kommunizieren
wie ein youtube
ich finde ja wissen sie ja so schade
finde ich habe mir diese pdf datei
durchgelesen und vieles von dem was da
drin steht ist sehr klug und gut
argumentieren zwar schon seiten der cdu
es ist wert dieses dokument mal zu lesen
über das sich alle gerade so lustig
machen diese pdf datei es ist und ich
habe nicht verstanden warum man diese
riesige chance die sich da bietet
nämlich diesen inhalt zu nehmen als
video zu produzieren dass sie nicht auf
ihrem handy haben und einfach mal der
öffentlichkeit zugänglich zu machen
was ist denn besser an einer pdf
schlacht als in einer video schlacht das
habe ich verstanden es ging darum ein
bisschen die debatte auch ein stück weit
zu versuchen zu versachlichen weil eins
ist auch klar das kann man doch auch im
video ja ja ich will sagen auf jeden
fall das was jetzt auch angesprochen ist
zum thema upload filter viel kritik die
dort ankommt ist auch nicht ganz
unberechtigt deswegen haben wir auch
eine lösung gefunden dass wir sagen wir
wollen der nationalen umsetzung keine
upload filter und dieses thema dann
müssen wir auch besser werden junge
leute zu verstehen upload filter carmina
fraktion vor ein paar wochen auf er ich
habe das ja ich bin ja in der jungen
union immer unterwegs ich habe sie zu
hastig wenn sie sagen wir müssen besser
werden müssen als partei deswegen besser
werden das zu verstehen wir dieses thema
artikel 13 upload filter ja das ist
schon aufgekommen schon vor über einem
dreiviertel jahr habe ich da schon bei
schülergruppen gab bei der jungen union
irgendwie und da sind halt themen wo wir
gucken müssen dass man das nicht so
upzugraden essen randthema auch jetzt so
und ich bin aber noch sagen zu diesem
ganzen wollte sagen waren sie das video
uns mitbringen und veröffentlich ja ich
will noch mal sagen mit dieser pdf datei
und diese debatte zu versachlichen
ja das ist schon wichtige anspruch weil
wir sind auch echt kurzatmig geworden in
all unseren debatten sowohl um
klimaschutz als auch blut filtern hätten
aber die art und weise wie darüber
berichtet wird dass es natürlich weil
ehrlicherweise die antwort der politik
auf reillys for future und der umgang
damit
wer war gar nicht zum teil der raum für
die ganz großen vertieften diskussion
sondern dann wird gefragt nach zwei
sätzen zitat dann wird gefragt nach dem
120 sekunden einordnung und das ist
schon auch wo man sagen muss da muss man
tiefer in das thema abzuschließen können
wir einfach sagen sie haben es
versammelt also die union es war kein
klares dementi möchte ich sein also ich
habe gedacht ich sollte ich so oft
gefragt das video zu machen ich habe
geliefert wie bestellt so und
kommunikativ
in der pdf nicht auch so was wie die die
die die währung von von parteien ist
vertrauen und der satz wird sehr
spannend da wir die überleben von
qliktech nie was genau uns beide
parteien leben vom vertrauen das ist
genau der knackpunkt denn ich glaube bei
dass das wiso video ist so erfolgreich
nicht nur weil riesengroßer youtuber ist
der normalerweise musikvideos sondern
ich glaube wenn wir jetzt gemacht hätten
um zerstörung der grünen hätte es keiner
von ihnen mitbekommt weil das wäre auch
gar nicht auf so eine große resonanz
gestoßen und man muss dazu sagen er ist
die reaktion darauf hat das video auch
nochmal gepusht ich das gefühl hatte
dass das thema der umgang mit dem die
werbung im internet vor allem aber
zunehmend überall ist authentizität
unglaubwürdig absolute authentizität und
dass daran kann man auch den erfolg von
youtube an zb und messen das ist bei der
politik natürlich genauso wichtig und da
da sind wir wieder bei dem knackpunkt
pdf oder video das ist der große
unterschied
interessant fand ich jetzt wirklich eben
was die ganz am schluss gesagt hat ich
habe man wollte ein video von mir aus
adenauer haus hat mich gebeten ich habe
die liebe sprechende aufsehen aber das
ist es die parteien cdu csu spd vor
allem sind so nach innen orientiert sie
sich ist wichtig ganz offensichtlich
dass kurz ausführen für sie ist wichtig
sie haben den auftrag bekommen sie haben
diesen auftrag erfüllt da draußen ist
das alles gar nicht angekommen ist gab
kein video von ihnen gab eine pdf
reaktion das ist draußen angekommen
mein appell ist wirklich nach auch nach
diesen dramatisch schlechten
wahlergebnissen gehen sie raus aus
diesem tunnel in dem sie sich immer nur
mit ihren eigenen flügeln und und
parteimitgliedern und untergruppierungen
beschäftigen und sich gegenseitig
vorwürfe machen die und junge union war
schuld am wahlergebnis nein da hab ich
wieder springen sie mal raus aus dem
tunnel total wichtig weil ja
mein wahlkreis gefangen beim penkuner
sportverein an der polnischen grenze und
überall anders da gibt es eine ganze
reihe von diskussionen wo man sagen muss
die finden hier gar nicht statt ja das
ist auch immer ein thema ja das ist für
mich auch eine lehre aus der europawahl
wenn wir sehen wie polarisiert unsere
vision schaden zwischen eigentlich ist
und wie groß die unterschiede sind und
damals jedenfalls der über alle das
zusammenzubinden auf vielen ebenen ist
das polarisiert und eben auch auf der
ich finde es einfach schade dass das
diese chance dass auf augenhöhe zu
beantworten dies einfach liegen
geblieben deswegen geht es auch darum
damit den botschaften besser
durchzudringen und auch zu sagen wo die
widersprüche sei es nicht die eine
wahrheit sondern das liegt immer
irgendwie im auslegen und heßlingen ist
für uns klar wirtschaft und umwelt da
geht es um beides irgendwie dabei machen
sie einfach mal ein schönes video und
dann machen wir heute jetzt auch ein
schönes gemacht so
[Applaus]
wie groß waren eigentlich wie groß war
denn eigentlich die erleichterung dass
am ende dann doch wieder die spd um die
ecke kam und ihnen dieses böse thema
weggenommen hat und wieder den fokus
komplett auf sich gezogen hat durch den
aal ist rückt kollege von von claudia
kade
das immer gerne robin alexander zitiert
diesbezüglich immer den schönen satz
immer dann wenn cdu und csu eine
übelriechende brühe anrühren kommt die
spd und gibt sie sich über kommen und
sie waren froh darüber
ehrlicherweise nicht also eine
ehrlicherweise nicht denn man muss man
ehrlich sagen die andrea nahles hat
anders als immer in der öffentlichkeit
der zum teil waren anders als in den
eigenen reihen bei uns in der fraktion
eigentlichen sehr sehr guten ruf und
sehr hohen stand gehabt weil sie
wirklich dafür bekannt war total
verlässlich zu sein
sachlich zu sein konsens und kompromiss
orientiert so sagen als arbeitsmittel ja
absolut und deswegen hat sie schon bei
uns auch ein hohes standing gehabt und
gerade die die aus der fraktionsführung
viel enger natürlich als ich also ganz
eng mit ihm zusammengearbeitet haben
die haben das natürlich schon bedauert
und insoweit bringt das auch ein stück
weit instabilität oder sind wir nicht
froh drüber und hoffen dass die
sozialdemokraten aber wieder auf linie
kommt mir jetzt gerade ist doch so das
war das perfekte ablenkungsmanöver
eigentlich schon wenn sie ehrlich sind
herren tor es hat ein bisschen die
reihen geschlossen der biologe als ein
youtube-video würdig seien geschlossen
bei der union die union kann sich jetzt
sozusagen als stabilität sowie der
bildung in der koalition
verstehen kann so ein bisschen die
eigene fehler analyse
vertagen wurde jetzt ja auch auf der
vorstandsklausur erstmal alles ein
bisschen auf die längere bank geschoben
es war brutal was in der spd mit andrea
nahles passiert ist aber andrea nahles
ist auch lang genug in der partei sie
hat selber mit ihren damaligen
vorgesetzten auch harte machtspiele
gesprächen waren es hat keine gefangenen
gemacht sie wirklich nicht deswegen
hatten sie ja vorhin einleiten ob das
jetzt so frauenfeindlich ist was da
passiert ist dann mache ich mal ein
fragezeichen
sie war jetzt auch erst die erste
parteivorsitzende bei der spd der das so
passiert ist müsste man jetzt mal noch
nur mal gucken wie es mit einer zweiten
wäre aber es ist eben auch vielen
parteivorsitzenden passiert und als
andrea nahles damals generalsekretärin
werden wollte und der damalige
parteichef franz müntefering das
überhaupt nicht wollte hat sie es
durchgesetzt wissen dass er dann
zurücktreten nur das baby und auch aber
sicher aber es gibt trotzdem einen
unterschied finde ich andrea nahles hat
damals sozusagen sich klar zu erkennen
gegeben die hat gesagt was auch ich
werde da antreten ich fordere dich
heraus politischer wettbewerb so wie es
die cdu ja auch bei der frage um den
vorsitzenden gemacht hat ein bisschen
heckenschützen mäßig jetzt genau die
leute bis heute kommen die leute die da
im verdacht stehen eine schöne intrige
angezettelt zu haben die kommen ja nicht
aus
hinter der hecke hervor genau deswegen
fand ich eigentlich schon alles gesagt
lasst uns doch jetzt wirklich mal eine
abstimmung machen über den
fraktionsvorsitz
er sagt vor der wahl was wirklich einen
kann ihn also wirklich eine ganz brutale
grätsche ist kommt vor der europawahl
lassen durchsickern ihr wollten sie als
fraktionsvorsitzende dann so dann
kandidiert doch mal gegen mich und das
hat tagelang hat sich dann keiner
bekannt tatsächlich und sie hat aber
natürlich hinter den kulissen und bei
der einen fraktionssitzung die dann
sondern mit sonder speziell mäßig
angesetzt wurde deutlich zu verstehen
bekommen dass aus allen möglichen
landesverbänden
die unterstützung bröckelt die die sie
halten wollten das muss man leider auch
sagen die hatten glaube ich den impetus
dass sie sie noch so lange halten wollen
bis sie schwierigen wahlen in
ostdeutschland stattfinden und man ihr
die schuld dafür auch noch ja so war es
dadurch ihr die schuld das ist das
wirklich so noch auf die latte strich
na ja wir haben zum beispiel jetzt
keinen neuen parteichef keinen neuen
fraktionschef sondern alles nur
kommissarische leiter war anna bild
schuld daran sollen bei dem osten die
wahlen verloren die ich meine es wird es
werden
wir haben jetzt eine harte niederlage
bei der europawahl erlebt man für die
sozialdemokraten aber die richtig krasse
abstürze die kommt ja erst noch
also in sachsen kann die spd froh sein
wenn sie zwei stellen wird und dafür
muss ja dann auch wieder irgend jemand
die verantwortung übernehmen wenn man
dieses was ich falsch finde wenn man
immer dieses spiel spielt so personal
auswechseln der nächste bitte
der neuanfang wie wir heute schon
mehrfach gehört haben es geht um inhalte
da muss jetzt wirklich mal in der
erwachsenen die halloween da schon so
durch und dann geht ihnen dann wirklich
die luft aus sich inhaltlich mal klar
aufzustellen so die lage wenn jetzt die
grünen übernehmen herm tor wären sie
bereit mit den grünen eine regierung zu
gehen
nur kathrin göring als juniorpartner
meine ich jetzt also bitte das wird so
das war's jetzt
ich bin da ganz unbesorgt erstmal nein
ich habe gehört das war nur eine übliche
reaktion darauf hat man hat city grün
sind die neue volkspartei
bei mir meinem wahlkreis in vorpommern
gibt es manche gemeinde haben die grünen
0 stimmen also so richtig kann das waren
sie in dieser woche erst einmal vorhin
sind sich aber ändern weil wir die
aussagen halten sie das video rassen
sondern da geht es wirklich darum in dem
man auch klar macht was es heißt grüne
politik balance zu machen die machen die
treffen nerv gerade beim thema klima das
richtig ja aber sie hat niemals ein your
partner in frage stellt sich gar nicht
getroffen stellt sich vielleicht stellt
sich überhaupt nicht und wir haben jetzt
schon eine andere regierung und ich
finde ja erstmal bemerkenswert den
reaktionen dass die grünen dann jetzt
sagen katrin göring eckardt erklärt
gestern ja also wenn jetzt dann die
groko scheitern sollte dann müssen wir
erstmal eine große koalition
koalitionsverhandlungen müssen wir
ausschließen sondern dann müssen wir
gleich starten die neuwahl wir wollen
alle mehr sitze ja das zeigt doch
eigentlich für die grünen ihre
schwerpunkte setzen nämlich zuallererst
auf sich selbst und nicht unbedingt da
ist jeden tag glücklicherweise ganz
anders natürlich na ja also ganz normal
wir haben jetzt wir haben jetzt keine
chronische angst vor einer neuwahl
ich glaube aber wir müssen schon schauen
was für das land gut geht dann frage ich
claudia kade abschließend die das
wahrscheinlich weiß wie lange hält diese
gruppe ganz schwierig zu sagen ich würde
mal sagen die dieser ostdeutschen
landtagswahlen die wird jetzt noch gegen
das noch durchgestanden von der großen
koalition danach glaube ich bin eben
auch tatsächlich ein neuer
parteivorsitzender bei der spd gewählt
werden soll oder eine frau dann
doppelspitze dann kommt es genau zum
schwulen die sie das eben sagt dann wohl
mit treten die dann an also wollen die
dann die partei die spd in der koalition
lassen oder wollen sie dann in sagen wir
wollen vorsitzende werden mit dem ziel
raus gehen
vielleicht muss das nicht unbedingt in
neuwahlen münden das ist die große frage
aber ich glaube bis zum herbst haben wir
noch das von den lügen mit der gruppe
also dann gilt das alte motto von
norbert blüm augen zu cdu in diesem
sinne waren erfolgreich dabei würde ich
auch sagen augen zu und durch
in diesem sinne herzlichen dank große
freude in eine stille krankheit sprechen